Now, before we jump in to actually solving some problems,
we're going to do the experiment ourselves.
We're going to calculate as a class the circumference of the earth.
Now, we're going to do this by having every single student and myself take some data.
And then, we're going to aggregate that data in the next unit and come to some consensus
about what the circumference of the earth is.
There will be errors and we'll talk about that.
This will be a big data set so we'll have to learn some skills about how to handle that,
but we'll figure that all out in the next unit, but for now we just need to collect the data.
In order to this, what you're going to need is a string or a stick.
For example, in the beginning I used earlier, I used a string with a weight attached to it,
because the string need to be completely straight.
You can also use the edge of a building as long as you know it's vertical,
and you can measure its height, or anything else that's straight and vertical.
You're going to need a measuring device, maybe a meter stick or tape measure or something like that.
Again, the units aren't going to matter because they cancel out when we compute ratios.
Next, you're going to need a sunny day, and I understand this could be tricky,
especially if you live in a region where it's not so sunny out.
Once you have a sunny day, you're going need to do is experiment as close to solar noon
on a flat surface as you possibly can.
Now, what's solar noon? Solar noon is when the sun is highest in the sky and it's not necessarily--
in fact, it generally doesn't occur at 12 o'clock.
There's a link below this video where you can figure out what solar noon is in your location,
and I hope this isn't too much of an inconvenience for you, but I think this experiment can be done
quite quickly, and I think it will be interesting to see the data that the class collects.
I hope you participate in this. Of course, you don't have to participate but it'd be great if you did.
Now, once you have everything you need, it's solar noon in your location, you have a sunny day,
and a flat surface, you have your measuring device, your stick or a string,
the procedure is basically what you saw in the previous video.
Make sure the string/stick is vertical. Measure the length of whatever object you're using.
In the case of the experiment I did that was the string with the mass on it.
Next, we're going to measure the length of the shadow and be sure to record both of these.
Then you're going to enter the data here. Now, entering data, well, what data do we need to enter?
We're going to be doing this experiment a little different than Eratosthenes,
because I don't want you to have to use a camel to measure distances between nearby cities.
Instead, what we're going to do is you're going to enter your object length
and just enter a number, you don't need to enter any units because, like we said, they don't matter.
Shadow length, enter that. Enter your true latitude.
This is the actual latitude of where you do the experiment and you can find this in the link below.
Next, your going to have to enter the month and the day. Now, why do we need to do that?
Think about that for a second.
Well ideally, you're doing this experiment on the summer solstice, which occurs around
June 21st or 22nd--that's the longest day of the year in the northern hemisphere.
Unfortunately, by the time this class comes out, it's going to be
too late to actually get the summer solstice.
But, it's still right in the middle of summer for the northern hemisphere and it's pretty close
to the solstice--so let's set to introduce a small correction to the data,
and that's something we'll talk about in the next unit.
But to introduce that correction, we are going to need to know both the month in which you
collect the data so that would be June or July and you can enter June as the number 6,
and July as the number 7--so month will either be 6 or 7.
And then, you can enter the day--so if you do this on July 1st, you'll enter 7 in the month field
and 1 in the day field--go ahead, get your data.
I am very excited to see what we come up as a class.